[Music]
so after thinking about it for almost 20
minutes the bide administration has
finally figured out the cause of inner
city violence which is on the rise
and you'll be surprised horn is not
defunding the police it's not the
lunatic
prosecutors elected by george soros the
ones who refuse to enforce the law it's
not even the fact
that almost nobody in places like that
has a dad at home that has no effect at
all
the feminists won't let you say that no
inner city violence is caused by
quote white supremacist ideology and
racism
oh right republicans
the confederates they did it we know
this because an internal biden
administration
training document obtained by human
events tells us so
candace owens is the host of candace she
joins us to assess kenneth owens thanks
so much
it's great to see you tonight i'm
starting to laugh it's just
i i mean they've already told us that
republicans are responsible for
defunding the police i think republicans
are actually are responsible for you
know they're responsible for invading
iraq okay fine
how are they responsible exactly for
gang murders in chicago it's like in a
remarkable sleight of hand blaming
republicans for that
right a city that has been democratic
for so long you can't
remember when there was the last time
there was a republican mayor or anybody
republican that was controlling chicago
um and listen it's so painfully
dishonest and you wonder why are they
saying this we know that black on black
crime is a huge issue we know that
something near
95 percent of black homicides are
committed by other black people these
are all things that we should be talking
about and trying to get to the bottom of
that
is that something do with poverty yeah
perhaps does that have anything to do
with white supremacy no i don't think
when a gang member a black gang member
kills another black gang member they
phone each other up and say
we have to do this because of white
supremacy that's definitely not what's
driving that
but the more interesting question to ask
ourselves is why is the bidet
administration doing this why are they
being so
painfully and obviously dishonest are
they not expecting people to call them
out and
the larger topic here that we should be
discussing is that what they're really
committed to
is trying to identify ideologues right
and i'm talking about in the cia
in the military in the department of
justice what they're really trying to do
is purge
the all of these um institutions of
common sense thinkers and replacing them
with people that are committed to their
ideologies right
nobody cares about what's right what's
wrong anymore it's all about fighting
for leftists
fighting for the biden administration
and doing whatever they say following
their marching orders no matter what
right trans people in the military
that's what they want they want
ideologues and not rational thinkers
this is all a part of a larger purge and
this is what comes before
a totalitarian regime takes power and i
say that seriously
i say that so seriously it's time to now
take a good look
at totalitarian regimes of the past of
communist nations
of today and of the past because we are
following
a very dangerous pattern right now the
biden regime as i like to call them is
following
a very dangerous pattern well yeah i
wish i could disagree with you
and and i and i have to say i mean the
purpose of government is to is to help
people
i mean supposedly that was the purpose
of it if you wanted
if you wanted to help people who were
dying
in our cities you wouldn't
provide a like transparently ludicrous
ideolo ideological explanation for you
to actually think about why this
is happening and how we can fix it but
they don't seem to be interested at all
in fixing it at all
that's exactly right because they don't
want to tell people the truth right you
brought up father absence of course
that's a truth
that would really hit at home is about
how we need to get these families
together they're not interested in the
truth they're interested
in power in order to maintain power the
masses cannot know the truth
man that's smart candace owens the big
picture i appreciate it great to see you
tonight
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else